now these Speaker of the House of
Commons John Bercow announced this week
that he will stand down either way no
general election is called or on the
31st of October whichever comes first
now one of the leading candidates to
replace him is Harriet Harman the former
deputy labor leader she joins us and now
thank you very much for being with us so
why do you think you're all better than
all of the other candidates to be the
next speaker well I think it's a very
difficult and challenging time for our
parliamentary democracy and the
divisions over brexit an additional
casualty from those divisions has been
public trust and confidence in our
Parliament and I believe that is very
serious indeed because if there's a
vacuum there then extremism can move in
and fill that gap so I think it's a task
of all MPs to rebuild trust and
confidence in our democracy but it's
going to be a central role for the
speaker and I'm putting myself forward
and there will be a range of very good
candidates and so there should be
because it's an important role at a very
challenging time for our Parliament what
do you mean by extremism well I think
that if people don't have confidence in
their MPs and in Parliament as an
institution then it leads people to go
outside that to try and make change and
the point about our system is that
everybody has their vote every MP has an
equal vote in the House of Commons and
that's the basis for our democracy and
creates stability and progress and
prosperity and without that there is a
very dangerous situation of polarities
of views and clashes that are not really
brought forward to the House of Commons
to be deliberated and decided on I mean
it is one of the casualties of the
divisions over brexit and we really need
to address that all MPs but also
centrally the speaker and I guess some
people would say it's not extremism
people just feel completely
disillusioned with Parliament with MPs
they look at what's happening and they
think actually this is a joke yes but if
people lack confidence and it's evident
all of us members of parliament we can
hear what people are saying
that they do like trust and confidence
in Parliament that is a problem we can't
just say well they're justified in that
our parliamentary democracy is the
foundation of how this country is run so
we have to recognize the scale of the
problem and actually work to address it
and what is your plan to try and rebuild
that trust then watch or watch your
pitch well I think that the speaker has
always had a very important role inside
Parliament making sure each MP is able
to have their voice heard every each and
every one and also that there's a good
relationship between Parliament and
government but I think now it's very
important for the speaker to have a role
in the country as a whole to speak up
for Parliament and explain what
Parliament is actually doing that's not
the job of government that's the job of
individual MPs but above all the speaker
but also listen to what people are
saying and between now and October the
14th when the House of Commons gets back
I'm going to be going around the country
actually listening to what people are
saying about Parliament not just on
specific party political issues but what
they're saying about Parliament and we
know that people feel that Parliament
should change more with the times that
it's old-fashioned that it's out of
touch and we need to address all those
issues so that's why I'm putting myself
forward if you are going to have any
chance of getting a job you're gonna
need some conservative MPs to support
you and you've always been a staunch
lean labour politician some would say
quite tribe or just want to have a look
for example at something said back in
2007 the truth is that the Tory Party is
still the nasty party I mean if you're a
Conservative MP and you read that why
would you vote for you well I think
everybody who's standing for Speaker all
the candidates will have been elected on
a party political platform so our system
is that we choose from within the body
of MPs to have somebody to be elected to
be the speaker and therefore all the
candidates will have put themselves
forward on a party political platform
but once they actually be elected to the
chair the task is to actually be
impartial and be neutral as between
different views within parliament but be
very strong in standing up for
Parliament in respect of whoever the the
government is to make sure that
Parliament can hold the government to
account so you simply have to become
impartial that's what all speakers have
done in the past and that's what I and
no doubt the other candidates would do
as well we've all got our political
views but once you get into the chair
you have to be neutral and I've been
leader of the house before which is also
quite a cross-party role and I've been
one of the government's nor office as
well which also requires you to act in
the public interest rather than the
party interest so I feel well capable of
doing that as you say about the
importance of leaving your own views to
one side when you become Speaker some
wild argued that John Barco didn't do
that and he there is a view among some
the Brett suitors in Parliament that he
is coming down on the remain side what's
your take on John back was a speaker I
think he's come down on Parliament side
and it's been a very conflicted time but
of course he doesn't have a vote but
what he does do and what it's right that
he should do is enable Parliament to
have it say even if that's not what the
government wants to hear and I think
that's why there's been criticism of him
I think there's also been criticism and
controversy because he's tried to make
the government more accountable to
Parliament and he's tried to modernize
and reform Parliament and I think he's
been right in doing that for example I
mean one small example we've got plenty
of bars in the House of Commons
he backed one of those bars being turned
into a nursery some of people found that
a change that they didn't agree with but
I think he was right on that and also
he's made ministers come to the House of
Commons more often when MPs have asked
for them to come in order to account for
what they're doing in their department
he's actually ordered them to come to
the House of Commons but I think that
although sometimes government find that
irritating it's good for government
because you can be developing a policy
behind closed doors and not be aware of
the flaws until you get to the House of
Commons and then you have to answer for
it
you're very supportive there John Barker
he also has been mired in allegations of
bullying as well that he's denied but if
you look at what Dame Laura Cook said
when she did a report into bullying in a
harassment empowerment
she found a culture of deference
subservience acquiescence and silence
and said people in management roles
including Barco should consider their
positions now you were somebody who
spent your career fighting for people
who come forward with these kind of
allegations to be taken seriously and to
be believed is this not a bit of a
conflict view well I think Dame Laura
Cox's report was very important indeed
and in fact the whole House of Commons
agreed that we should move forward and
have an independent complaints procedure
so that if somebody makes a complaint
against an MP that it's not judged by
MPs but it's judged independently that
was last year it is still not been
implemented so really it's a very
necessary reform we have to take forward
because what happens is people have
allegations but they don't make
complaints and put them into the system
because they don't have confidence in
the system so the way to deal with that
is to make sure that you do have a good
culture of respect and integrity in the
House of Commons by ensuring that there
is a proper complaint system which we
don't have at the moment how important
is it for the next-biggest be a woman
well I think it is I mean we've we've
had a hundred and fifty seven speakers
so far in our Parliament's history only
one woman ever
now that's partly because Parliament
used to be a parliament of men politics
was what men did women abided by the
decisions and men made them but things
have changed and in fact Parliament's
changed we've now got more hundred more
than 200 women members of the House of
Commons and I think it would show that
Parliament has changed have a woman in
the chair we've got a man as Prime
Minister a man as leader of the
Opposition as a man as leader of the SNP
the third largest party if we put a man
in the chair it will render all those
women invisible and I think we do need
to show women and men in the country
that parliament has changed it has
modernized one of those big changes is
that
women and men are on an equal footing
putting a woman in the chair will show
that in anyway after 600 years having
only managed one woman I think it's time
for the next you you're the mother of
the house the longest continuous serving
at female MP your first select in 1982
you were saying there about how the
number of women has increased in
Parliament but at the same time it feels
to me that there are sort of new
challenges if you like whether it's
social media abuse you've heard these
peripheries about MPs having panic
buttons and so on do you think things
have got better or worse for women in
the time even in Parliament
well I think in some ways they've got
better because there are more women
putting on the agenda issues that would
never have been regarded as politically
significant before like domestic
violence like child care like maternity
leave but also there's a backlash with
ever whenever this progress there's
always a backlash and there is some
misogynists who believe that women
should be just shutting up not actually
speaking up in public and social media
allows people anonymously to really do a
tirade of abuse and threat which is on
all MPs but particularly on women and
views in that yourself--all not so much
myself but we have actually lost a woman
MP with Joe Cox being murdered we nearly
had the murder of another woman MP these
are very serious threats and our
democracy rests on the idea that people
vote for their MPs and then those MPs
must be able to get on with their job
and vote the way they believe in without
responding to threats and intimidation
so I think ensuring that there is
respect of trust and confidence in MPs
and that MPs are properly protected is
also a very important part of the job of
the next speaker